alright
[Music]
hello how are you greetings come out for me
or with your briefing today wednesday
november 25 president-elect joe
biden officially won all six
electoral votes in the state of nevada
the supreme court formally approved
the results of the elections on tuesday  elections
for the state in presidential contention
and thus also closed the window to
request a recount of votes now the
last step in the certification of the
votes is in the hands of the governor of
the styps swap state and despite the fact that the
results of the election are already in  its
last step to be formalized
there are several lawsuits in force that continue to
challenge the elections today as he will
hear the request for a new
election in the congressional race of
andy rothman who is requesting a
new election while this tuesday
a judge rejected the request of iu  by
baker who lost his
state senate race by more than 600 votes
against cannes arrow democrat  the
judge dismissed his petition because
he found no evidence of
widespread voter fraud
and having another election in this race
will limit the right to vote for
certain voters
and there are changes to the homes of certain
test sites during this week
feria da hoy el centro  The test center at
Thomas & Mack will be available from 8 in
the morning to 4 in the afternoon, while
the center they assume will also limit
its services until 4 in the afternoon
all this week, as well as the
self-service test center at the tax station hotel.
announced that it will be closing on Saturday
all places recommend that you make your
appointment but do not require them and
tomorrow is thanksgiving it is anticipated that
millions of people will travel for the
holiday bridge for this reason
mccarran airport is taking
precautionary measures and will only be
allowing ticket holders to
enter their buildings and waiting rooms
by security management
Department of Transportation says it has
screened at least 3 million
passengers to date over the weekend this
past Sunday was the busiest at
checkpoints at the airport
since last March the triple-A
says Las Vegas' is the  most popular destination
to travel in the western zone of the country
for action holidays
now we turn to the
weather forecast, a sunny day is expected with a maximum of
63 degrees and a minimum of 41
degrees and get ready because the breezes are coming
One beautiful day I
came out Jaramillo and this was an illusion in
Spanish
[Music]